il est temps maintenant de retrouver
notre page et et vous le savez chaque
jour david jouillat et nathanaël le
maire nous propose une nouvelle balade
en touraine déplacements doux pour
vacances déconnecté nathanel on vous
retrouve ce soir à l'aérodrome d'amboise
d'hyères et vous avez pris de la hauteur
aujourd'hui et on a aussi pris l'air
parce que sur cet avion un biplan il y a
un sacré ventilateur vous allez le voir
on a choisi en fait de découvrir la
touraine vue du ciel
il ya bien sûr les châteaux renaissance
qui s'y prêtent à ce type de vision mais
il ya aussi tout l'environnement naturel
et vous allez le voir visiter tout ça en
biplan c'est un bon plan donc ça va pour
toi tu es bien attaché ça va très bien
pas de soucis tu parles bien dans le
micro très très près là comme ça et puis
tu peux me regarder dans l'intro viseur
qui est juste à droite
d'accord c'est parti pour un baptême de
l'air un peu rétro au départ de
l'aérodrome de dierre amboise un avion
biplan propose des balades touristiques
la vallée de la loire le cher les
châteaux sont avoir vu du ciel
une autre façon de découvrir la touraine
fonction qu'il vient empoisonner
chercher dans son environnement droite
la douce sans piqué ni en une demi heure
de vol les joyaux de la renaissance et
leurs jardins sont survolés amboise
chenonceau chaumont se révèle à la
verticale et c'est vraiment magnifique
ce qu'on les voie du dessus et du coup
on peut voir vraiment tous les petits
détails du jardin on voit les faits ce
qui passe en dessous et ses explosifs
après les châteaux en hélicoptère ou en
montgolfière voici venu le temps de la
balade en biplan ça séduit par ce petit
caractère bucolique en fait revenir un
petit peu dans l'aviation d'autrefois
qui était sympathique parce qu'on a une
très belle région aussi à découvrir
et puis c'est des vols très très doux
donc même les gens qui ont une petite
appréhension c'est pas des figures de
manège n'y a pas de voltige les
décollages sont très doux les attaches
très doux des virages voilà être à taux
très faibles et donc c'est vraiment pour
se faire plaisir
donc je pense que c'était l'idée une
idée il ya beaucoup de cadeaux comme ça
et puis des gens qui viennent se faire
plaisir par passion aussi
pour les passagers la sensation d'un vol
blue s'ajoute à la beauté des paysages
ce qui est plaisant c'est vraiment
d'avoir le visage aux vins est d'être à
l'air libre de pouvoir voir un peu tout
en tournant la tête n'y a pas de vitre
qui nos gènes et on a les sensations bas
de l'avion vraiment dans l'air une
aventure hors du temps à vivre
les cheveux dans le nord vous l'avez vu
cet avion a un petit côté vintage un
petit côté rétro nous sommes avec
l'heureux propriétaire de ce biplan
patrick plançon expliquez nous pourquoi
en 2015 aller rechercher un avion sur ce
modèle très anciens alors bien sûr on a
des avions avec des verrières qui
peuvent voyager à plus de 200 kilomètres
heure mais là ce que je trouvais
intéressant dans celui là c'est que je
peux apporter une personne à l'avant qui
va être toute équipée et on va pouvoir
faire un vol à 115 kilomètres-heure et
redécouvrir la région de la touraine qui
a énormément de châteaux comme vous le
savez en bois sur montceau alors quel
intérêt d'utiliser une vitesse lente
avec un avion très très très planant
pour faire ce genre de visites pourquoi
vous avez vous lu finalement partager ce
plaisir d'un vol un peu à l'ancienne
l'avions déjà lui ne peut pas voler plus
vite que 120 kilomètres heure mais c'est
intéressant parce que son comportement
en l'air et puis la façon dont on peut
observer le ciel et puis le sol permet
d'avoir cette petite balade bucolique
comme dans un cabriolet aujourd'hui
voilà vous pourriez faire ça tout seul
vous avez choisi d'en faire profiter les
gens à travers une activité un projet
touristique
pourquoi ce choix de valade emmener un
passager avec vous alors pas partager
une passion je pense que c'est vraiment
vraiment important je pense que c'est ce
que je fais j'aime bien voler avec à
deux personnes et partager la passion du
vol
c'est très important pour moi
aujourd'hui
au dessus de la loire et de découvrir un
petit peu tous ces trésors
quels sont les retours que vous que vous
avez quand les gens descendre de votre
biplan alors en général donc ça se passe
toujours très bien je vous rassure les
gens quand ils descendent sont vraiment
enchanté et les gens qui offrent aussi
des cadeaux à d'autres comme ça sont
également aussi enchanté donc voila et
moi ça me fait plaisir d'avoir des gens
contents sur ces voleurs voilà donc que
c'est les vols en biplan qui sont
proposés au départ de l'aérodrome de
dierre amboise une activité touristique
récente que vous pourrez retrouver
facilement sur notre site internet
voilà merci beaucoup nathanaël on vous
retrouve demain dans le 19h et je crois
que vous serez sur l'eau il y aura
d'autres surprises